i would like to send out a shout out to
brenda shane or thailand from sioux city
iowa home of our affiliate ktiv news 4.
brenda made this amazing pumpkin art for
us look how good you look drew by the
way i will say i totally recognize
myself immediately 100
okay well next we have a fantastic guest
joining us you know her from what i like
about you and as a key player in almost
every single ryan murphy's merry band of
actors all the shows she's currently in
two roles in american horror story
double
[Applause]
you for having feature ryan murphy has
like taken over the world with his
storytelling and his franchises what's
it like to be a part of that tribe it's
a dream come true the greatest thing i
could have asked for as an actor it's
the most fun
and also personally incredibly rewarding
um
these people have all become my dearest
friends so and not just the actors on
the show but the crew and i mean and
every department we're all super close
and also the work is intense you know
the hours are long the subject matter is
intense so you really like you're in the
trenches together so you kind of trauma
bond to everybody in the best way oh i
love you
but that makes it sound traumatic it's
not traumatic it's fun but you know when
you work good times
okay are you guys ready to hit a few
headlines yes we help all right first
we're going to start with uh nightmare
first dates we've all had them but can
you top this one the new york post
reports tick talkers elise myers went
viral it all started when she got a
message from a man on a dating app that
said i like your face let's get some
food elise drove to his house then he
directed her to the nearest taco bell
drive-through and then this happened
this is just a snippet take a look we
get to the speaker and he just leans
over and goes i would like 100 hardshell
tacos thank you
we get to the window
he does one of these numbers i'm like
did you forget your wallet he's like
yeah i was like do you need me to pay
he's like yeah
i'm like yeah
[Music]
she's a great storyteller by the way you
have to watch this video she is her
comedic timing her dry tone um and she's
super cute she's married now and she
calls her current husband a total smoke
show
elise i am dying for you to come on the
news and talk dating will you please
come here we love you yeah he ordered
100 taco girl that's nacho man okay
that's not good and apparently it didn't
stop there back at his place they ate
their tacos in silence and then his dad
who was there leaned over and asked
elise if she wanted to go see his studio
creepy uh that's when she took the rest
of the tacos and ran out the door
that was her worst first date ever do
you have a worst first date oh yes i do
oh i'd love to hear about it somebody
asked me out and i was looking forward
to it and i showed up and the first
thing he said to me as soon as he looked
at me was why are you wearing a lot of
makeup
well this is a bad tone to start this
off with so we got in the car and he
talked about his ex-girlfriend the
entire time in the car at the dinner and
then i was like i gotta get out of this
and he was like no but wait i have a
birthday party a friend's birthday party
i'd love if you'd come and i was like
maybe this is where things are gonna
take a better turn and we went to the
birthday party and he did not speak to
me or acknowledge me the entire time and
then i i finally got home and then he
called me the next day and said i had
the greatest time with you and i would
really love
to see you again and i just felt like
did i hallucinate this entire experience
like was this a dream that i had that
isn't a real thing it wasn't great what
did you say what did you let him out
easy no i said that was the single word
because you really help some poor woman
and that is how i'm sure that's exactly
and i said you literally did not look at
me or speak to me and spoke about your
ex-girlfriend the entire time you got to
do better you gotta do it oh my god i
love you more for more and more and more
leslie i would love if you'd take the
next story okay for your next date good
or bad
why not try out the kitten heel
in style reports it's the next big shoe
trend people are leaning into the teeny
tiny heels and sandals slings and even
boots drew
do kitten heels make you want to purr or
hiss yes for sure oh no i have short
legs i'll give you an example those are
great there we go okay all right i'll
show you why are you serious she comes
in front of the desk you see my legs
oh there she goes okay
that's my real leg
do you want that leg
or this leg
we all have our assets
and we all have you know our other
things but i know how to work with what
i got and i can't support the kitten
heel i have to say i do like a kitten
heel i i feel like it's sort of that
in-between world of i don't have to
commit to a big heel and i can but it's
a little fancier than a flat it it has
its place i sort of i'm rooting for a
kitten heel when i see it it's like you
know it's like a little heel that one
day will grow up to be a big heel
well actually speaking of things that
grow up i think this is a perfect
transition um i really wanted to ask you
leslie before we go we're rounding the
quarter um to november which is national
adoption awareness month and i was
really moved by your history with this
particular
pertinent meaningful subject and i was
wondering if you would enlighten us
about your journey i am thrilled that
you wanted to talk about this today
because this is my most favorite thing
on earth to talk about i was lucky
enough to be adopted and my daughter is
adopted so i know it from both sides and
to me it's been the most magical
incredible
life-affirming experience i don't know
how i could love my daughter anymore
than i do i couldn't and i don't know
how i could love my parents anymore than
i do adoption has been talked about
since i was a kid growing up like in the
80s it was sort of this like sad
lifetime movie
discussion and i just never ever had
that experience and even as a little kid
i was always like i'm adopted because
i'm so special and i just always feel
like if you're adopted i don't know if
you could have been wanted any more than
you are i mean you're the most wanted
kid so i love your journey i celebrate
you thank you thank you for telling that
story i really i
let's adopt each other now
thank you so much coming to the news
desk and making it a better place thank
you thank you for having me this was so
much fun
[Applause]
[Music]
you